une conférence de presse attendue la
sélection piste pour les championnats du
monde de berlin était dévoilée ce rendez
vous organisé du 26 février au 1er mars
fera office de test à quelques mois des
jeux olympiques
on a une équipe de france qui est très
bien dans sa trajectoire par rapport à
tokyo et du coup qui va aborder ces
championnats du monde à la fois pour y
faire des résultats pour performer est
ce que c'est important est à la fois
également je pense pour prendre de
l'assurance la confiance là où il ya
besoin dans la construction vers tokyo
sur les épreuves d'endurance on
retrouvera notamment à certains bryan
coquard champion du monde en 2015 sur la
piste du vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
je me sens plutôt bien à vrai dire j'ai
crié et repris l'entraînement va dire le
1er décembre
et voilà ces derniers entraînements sur
piste sont plutôt plutôt encourageant je
participerai à la course aux points en
championnat du monde je suis champion
d'europe en titre
bien évidemment j'ai envie de envie de
bien faire du côté du sprint pas de
surprise on retrouve les désormais
incontournables grégory baugé sébastien
vigion ou encore mathilde de gros mais
l'une des stars de cette équipe de
france sera quentin lafargue et binoy
licencié au vc jusqu'à y avait remporté
l'or sur le kilomètre et large en
vitesse par équipes sur les derniers
mondiaux en 2019
c'est toujours un moment important cette
sélection est et ce championnat du monde
tous les ans qui revient mais qui fait
toujours plaisir à afin de porter porté
les couleurs des équipes de france au
plus haut niveau donc je l'attendais je
l'espérais et je suis content de faire
partie du collectif la fédération
française n'a pas voulu annoncer
d'objectif chiffré de médailles sur les
championnats du monde les premières
épreuves sont programmées le mercredi 26
février à partir de 13 heures